(pleasant orchestral music)
(bat cracking)
- [Narrator] For millions
of Japanese people,
springtime means one thing: baseball.
But what a fan probably
doesn't think about:
what happens to all those
broken baseball bats?
Well, one chopsticks
manufacturer has an answer.
(bat cracking)
(crowd cheering
(pleasant orchestral music)
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] Wood from the aodamo tree
was popular for making
fine wooden products
and professional baseball bats.
But because of forest tree mismanagement,
the species was in trouble.
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] Instead of
contributing to the problem,
Mr. Uratani had an idea.
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] With that, Mr. Uratani
put his plan into motion.
(speaking in foreign language)
(pleasant orchestral music)
(bat cracking)
- [Narrator] With the profits from
these baseball chopsticks,
Mr. Uratani has joined
baseball leagues and teams
to donate to a group planting
a new forest of aodamo trees.
(speaking in foreign language)
(bat cracking)
(crowd cheering)
(electronic dinging)